-Tiny bit scared.
-All right, no.
It's going to be fun.
Here's how it works.
We're going to have a number
of mystery objects
brought out in front of us,
and our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
-Just feeling.
-You put -- Yeah, just feeling.
And I'm freaked out
about this game already.
All right, so since I'm the
host, I'm going to go first.
That's what it says on the card.
Why?
Oh, my gosh.
All right, let's get the object.
Why? Why?
-Can I look at what it is?
-Yeah, yeah.
You can look, yeah.
Ugh. Okay.
-Oh, okay.
-All right.
I don't know if you're -- if
that's your poker face or what.
All right, I'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
Here we go.
-Watch out there.
[ Laughter ]
-It's freaking me out.
It feels warm or something.
It's warm!
I don't like it, whatever it is.
It's really grossing me out.
This is so odd.
I can't even describe this.
I'm not looking at anyone.
Ah! Oh, God!
Oh, man, oh, man.
Can I just put my right hand?
-That's cheating.
You have to do both.
-Oh, gosh!
Ah!
I hate this game so much!
I'm going to freak out
right now!
All right.
I'm doing it. Here we go.
Hey-o!
[ Audience cheering ]
Ah, ah, ah!
Ah, ah, ah, ah!
Shush! Shush, shush, please.
Shush, please. Shush.
Ah. Oh, my God.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh, it's marshmallow Peeps.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gosh, you guys are the worst!
You are all the worst people!
You were cringing.
You were like --
Oh, my gosh!
The worst!
My own audience turned on me!
Oh, my God!
Do not trust, especially her.
Oh, my gosh.
-That one?
-Yes. She was making faces.
Like, "Eh, don't touch it."
All right.
All right, Kate, you know we
would never do anything wrong
or rude to you,
so you have 30 seconds.
-Okay.
[ Audience groans ]
All right.
-They're not "oohing" that.
They're excited about --
We get to talk about
your new show, "The Widow."
It's going to be fun.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
We have a deal about
I can't touch vomit.
I'll touch poo if I have to.
-No.
I would never do that.
Really, I would
never ever, ever.
I would never do that.
-I'm phobic of --
-Aah!
-I don't like poo.
But I'm phobic of vomit.
And I'll go home.
-No, stop saying "poo"
and "vomit."
We're not doing either.
No, this is network television.
Here we go!
But you never know
what it might be.
Wait.
No poo?
-No, if I have to, I'll do poo.
But vomit, I'm going home.
-Well, then I think you'll
be close on this one.
-Is it poo?
[ Laughter ]
They wouldn't do poo to me,
would they?
-Not quite.
-Is it going to bite me?
Is it?
-You know,
I'm dabbing right now.
I'm so excited.
Just go for it.
-Stop it.
-Go for it.
Come on!
-Oh, God.
-Oh, no!
[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Why were they wet?
Ah!
It's sticky.
It's sticky and wet.
It's a poo.
It's a huge poo.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Is it?
You can grab it.
-Ooh, is this alive?
-No.
-Oh, wait a minute.
-Is it a cinnamon roll?
-Yes!
-Yeah!
-How did you guess that?
I love it.
[ Laughs ]
How did you guess that?
-Way to fake me out.
-I mean, it was good, right?
Yeah.
No, I would never do that.
To Kate Beckinsale,
are you kidding me?
Thank you.
My turn, unfortunately, again.
Ah!
All right.
Here we go.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Ah!
Come on.
Get in there.
-[ Breathing deeply ]
See, now the audience
is playing the game.
And I don't like it at all.
Whoo!
-Remember how lovely Peeps were.
Remember how lovely Peeps were.
He's just like this.
Oh, God.
-Ah! Is it moving?
Is it moving?
-No, but --
[ Laughs ]
-I'm freaking out, man.
Come on, dude.
-Yeah.
-Oh, God.
Freaking out right now.
All right.
Ah! Oh, my gosh.
I hate this game so much.
-This is slightly less
of an Easter theme.
Oh, Jimmy.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Is it fruit?
It's a pile -- Ew.
Is it worms?
-Yes!
-Ew!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's bad.
-Get the [bleep] out of here.
-This is the worst game ever.
That was worms.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh!
-That wasn't good.
-Everyone knows I don't like
any of that stuff!
Aah! Yes, I need --
The Purell's not enough.
Oh, my God.
-Oh, God.
-Not a big deal.
I'm fine with worms.
Are you kidding me?
I'm like a total outdoorsman.
[ Laughter ]
All right, Kate, you're up.
It's can't be -- Come on,
it's got be easier than that.
Here we go. Yeah.
Here we go.
Aah!
[ Audience groans ]
No!
-No.
-Oh!
That lady in the mustard
yellow's made me scared.
Don't.
-Ohh.
-Do I wish it was poo?
-Oh.
-I wish it was poo.
Don't say that!
What?
Can you see it?
Can't see it.
[ Audience screams ]
Stop!
You guys.
Oh, don't!
It's so much scarier when
it's really you doing it.
[ Audience screams ]
Oh, stop!
Oh. Oh, what's that?
It's leathery.
Was it the underbelly
of something?
-Ohh.
-What is -- What is that?
What is that?
[ Audience screams ]
Did it move?
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah, time is up.
-I didn't know
there was a time limit.
I was gonna be here all day.
-It was a giant frog.
-No!
Was it really?
-Look at it.
Yeah, he's cute.
-Oh, God.
Oh, God.
-What did you think it was?
It was leathery.
-It was leathery.
I thought it was something's
underbelly, and it was.
-It was.
You were actually right.
Oh, this is the last round.
Thank goodness.
The final round.
-I'm light-headed.
-For this one, we're both
going to get the same item.
-At the same time?
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't like the view.
No, it's not good.
It's not a good sign.
-We're going to get
the same item.
The first person
to guess it wins.
-So we go in one side each?
-Yes.
[ Audience shouting ]
Ah!
[ Cymbals crash ]
-What was...
-I touched your hand.
Was it Jimmy's hand?
-Ah!
Ah!
[ Audience shouting ]
-Did you feel something?
-It felt warm or something.
-Warm?
-Yes.
Ah!
-It's alive. It's alive.
Aah!
It's a person.
It's a man!
-Ah!
-Is it a man?
-Is it a person?
-No, stop looking.
Is it a man?
Is it my stepdad?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's moving around a lot.
It's a person.
-What is it, a hand?
-Who is that?
-That's a foot!
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Get the --
Where's the Purell now?
Yes.
-That was a foot.
Whose foot was that?
-I have no idea.
That was Tom Cruise's foot.
All right, thanks
to Kate Beckinsale.